I'm sorry
it's not a real podcast we tweeted out
but as many of you guys probably figured
out we aren't recording a podcast a
speaker we didn't record podcaster this
week just because we've been moving for
so long so many days it's been 84 years
our studio up there isn't quite set up
either we do have some lights to work on
like what's still waiting for some
furniture and doing stuff we still have
been unpacked all about this so yeah
what same clothes wearing a lot of what
we need in order to record a podcast is
not finished yet we can actually show
you though if you want right we can take
them up to the room it looks very good
so far and we still need to get the
green-screen back from the dry cleaners
they've been calling me oh okay well cuz
as you guys remember the green screen
needs to be up against a door that went
outside which even when we moved in was
like you could tell had water damage and
whatever there's a patron comes I'm
three yard and it got like water damage
so it's so we still don't have our old
green screen yet with who's shown the
room okay all right well this is the
podcast room and this is my table so the
green screen obviously is gonna go right
there are like on camera monitor which
is right here this is where so basically
this would be on top of the camera and
this is how we would see ourselves but
when we are all the way over there is
like hard to see on this tiny thing so I
took my little college TV and now that's
the longer so good youth for it so we
got to put the green screen up then we
got to install these lights we got some
cool new lights from a company called
aperture
so we have no way to audio record
hopefully some if it doesn't it doesn't
know yeah we had that cuz we're
splitting up the rooms since now the
gaming room and streaming room is by
itself we needed some more resources for
the podcast room to stand alone ie a
recording audio PC so we wanted to just
kind of give you a little look it's
getting this
dink-dink Minds money yeah so this is
pretty much why we could community
couldn't have a podcast ready for this
week but we wanted to just show you guys
why and hello and also I want to be
assembling this room like this week and
you can see the behind the scenes on the
blog so yeah well I mean we've only been
here for since Friday Friday night yeah
and today's Monday look we we had this
weekend first of all my body like shut
off like Saturday and even yesterday
like I could not sleep enough it was
like so exhausting it is just something
else my body actually hurts I just like
I feel it's just like mentally zapped to
I can't even focus on anything even
streaming last night I was like what I
hope happening but hopefully next week
we'll have at least something set up so
we can have the podcast yeah we'll have
the green screen commune and know we'll
have enough to record a podcast actually
I might just get it thank you guys for
all the love and support and don't miss
about the movie you guys being excited
about the move is so cool to us but
we'll be live on Twitch just like every
night this week
oh hey we're not recording right now are
we do you care there's a dog bed for
them so now when we record a podcast
they won't be crying at our feet well
they probably spit
what Silva always kind of Marvel's
little clause in this house like you can
hear okay no that's why his name is mr.
marbles sign phone anyway guys dink dink
we'll see you guys on the next week's
podcast and on Twitter and on the vlogs
and everywhere else but is this our
first non podcast uploaded to this
channel yeah rip we had a good streak
it's all right